hello everyone what's going on guys this
is rob and and man has been if you've
been a little while been a little bit
since i made a video blog I'm talking to
you guys I have been dealing with some
personal issues some very important
personal family things which I'm not
going to go into you but they're still
ongoing and it may be that it will
affect future uploads but at the moment
things are for the most part stable is
that's what I'll put it but um but holy
[ __ ] have you guys seen the trailer for
Avengers 2 age of Ultron I know you have
the video the trailer was up for like
two days and it's got 30 million views i
wish one of my videos could be uploaded
for two days and get 30 million of years
that's that's just stupid viral that
movie looks [ __ ] amazing I know that
it's not going to have anything to do
with the age of Ultron like movie but or
with the age of Ultron comic book story
but [ __ ] I mean Man Captain America's
shield is broken everybody's like just
kind of freaked out and just like man
everything sucks oh my god James Spader
the best voice on the planet to play
ultra my favorite my favorite part is at
the end of the trailer when he says
there's there's a he says there's no
more strings on me that's oh man I'm so
excited for this movie I am I am so
psyched for Avengers 2 age of Ultron
it's going to be man it's going to be so
awesome I'm innocent man man that's
gonna be so bad assets it's why the
trailer looks look spectacular um there
are some things about the trailer too
though and this is what I'm curious
about this is what I'm curious about did
you guys catch this stuff because the
trailer was shining giant you know
purple letters all over the screen
saying hey this is a bad Avengers 2 age
of Ultron we knew that the question was
did you catch the small stuff did you
catch the little giveaways there are
some major things that Marvel gave away
in that trailer whether or not it's
going to be with regards to like the
movie itself or it's going to be future
projects the first thing is of course I
think most everybody's figured out now
that the city in the beginning of
years to be what Conda that appears so
that the movie for the most part is
going to take place maybe in South
Africa or some African territory or
something like that the reason why i say
that i think that city is what Conda is
because Captain America's shield is
broken and if you guys remember in
Captain America the First Avenger we
learned his shield was made out of
vibranium and for those of you guys will
follow the comics or they watch my video
on Black Panther which you should have
there's no reason why you shouldn't have
um black panther and Wakanda is the hope
you guys get here there's a train coming
by my house but um what Conda is home to
the largest and the only as far as I
know reservoir of vibranium meaning that
if Captain America shield is going to be
remade they're going to have to get
involved with Black Panther somehow
they're going to have to find a way to
attain vibranium but the other the other
reason for this the other reason for
this and I'm so excited about this
ulysses klaw and i came over the actors
name i think it's andy serkis I believe
that's his name he was a guy that played
Bilbo bad or not Bilbo Baggins [ __ ] I
got the played Gollum I think and and
The Hobbit and I think it may have
played a few other things but he is it
looks like it looks very very very
similar if it's not him then Marvel is
doing something weird but he looks like
Ulysses Klaw now if you Lisi's claw is
going to be in this movie are going to
have a cameo that means we're definitely
going to be stepping into Black Panther
territory it means we're definitely
going to be getting into Black Panther
stuff in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and this is a big deal because as we
know Black Panther went on to eventually
become an Avenger and so what this could
also mean is that Marvel is really
looking at the idea of what they're
going to do with the Avengers and the
model Cinematic Universe franchises
beyond captain america and Tony Stark
and so on so I'm really curious to see
me right now potentially we could have
new avengers in the form of the Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver who will most
likely defect from Ultron because it
looks like they're serving Ultron in
this in this this movie but they
couldn't effect from Ultron they could
join up as part of the Avengers then we
could have an man Scott Lang and
possibly I don't know what they're going
to do with Hank Pym as i understand it
Hank Pym supposed to be old because he's
being played by Michael Douglas so I
doubt he'll actually be an active
Avenger because they're just be too old
to do anything but you're going to have
ant-man Scott Lang and then you can have
black panther
and so you'd have like this really
really cool mishmash but but regardless
you know at this point it's really too
early to know it's really too early to
know for sure what it is they're going
to do we've got we have two and a half
minutes of footage for what they could
possibly do now here's the kicker here's
what I really think is cool
chronologically I guess historically
speaking when it comes to Marvel
Cinematic Universe trailers challenge
for the movies they always go in
chronological order very rarely has
Marvel ever had an instance where by you
have a trailer that doesn't reveal
things or chronological order the only
exception to that that I can think of is
is Iron Man but for Captain America the
Winter Soldier it was the same way for
Captain America the First Avenger if you
go back and watch the trailers after
having seen the movie it all takes place
in chronological order the fact that
Ultron was revealed to us at the end of
the trailer as like the full-on form of
the whole Trotter near the end I guess
also kind of in the middle to means that
it'll probably be around the middle of
the movie maybe a little bit later into
the movie before Ultron takes on this
cool uber form but the other thing too
that's really interesting is we're not
seeing Ultron with like adamantium all
right we're just seeing Ultron with with
like metal now whether or not this means
model doesn't own the rights to
adamantium I don't know adamantium is
largely associated with Wolverine now
its associated with other people to like
Lady Deathstrike but because of the fact
that she's part of the x-men franchise
then Fox owns the rights to that so I
would go as far as to speculate that
most likely will never see an adamantium
Ultron unless Fox gives the rights to
the x-men back but that doesn't mean
they can't replace it with something
else like vibranium a vibranium Ultron
um what this means to me for the most
part when you look at the idea won the
title of the film the age of Ultron and
to the format that Ultron is taking
indicates to me that this is not going
to be like like a one-shot for Ultron
Ultron's not going to show up in this
story after being created show up in
this movie after being created and then
be killed and go away and be gone
forever I think Ultron's going to come
back because Ultron has always been one
of the most enduring for photos of the
Avengers he's always fought the Avengers
on several occasions on a multitude of
occasions um not only that when you look
at the I think it was what am I thinking
annihilation conquest where you had like
you have the man one of my thing of the
Phalanx Ultron had more or less like
uses conscious mind to absorb the thing
links to a degree and to the
leave them and so what I did is it
basically launched like this universal
scale storyline centering around Ultron
as a villain and it also included Ultron
switching minds with Adam warlock and of
course we know Adam warlock is going to
be in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so
it could be that sometime later down the
line we see Ultron come back and launch
some massive attack against you know the
planet earth yet again or involve a
multitude of superheroes again we don't
know but it's so fun to speculate it's
so fun to to talk about this stuff I
love and you guys were screaming at me
about it you guys are sent me so many
Twitter messages you guys are said me
love me so many comments you know Rob
talk about the age of Ultron to trailer
like do some speculation push your
Marvel knowledge to the task as you guys
can tell I'm excited you know but um but
yeah you know I'm it's it looks like
it's going to be good it looks like it's
going to be really really good so I'm
really excited about it but anyway um so
the other thing too is is because of the
family issues that I've been dealing
with of course we haven't had the weekly
pool podcast I mean I'm in charge of the
podcast I won the podcast that's how me
and bitty and sound have vivid
everything up Sal has this whole stuff
on his end bidding has the stuff on his
end and I'm working on the podcast so of
course my job is try to get people on
the potty house and so on but because of
the family issues that have been taking
place because of the fact that Benny's
been out of town so on for business and
everybody was just generally worn out
after comic-con we haven't had the
podcast for the last two or three weeks
that will probably change next week I
don't really see an instance right now
why the podcast will not be available on
thursday now again I have some family
things going on so it may be that it
gets cancelled i'm not going to prom i'm
not going to promise you guys the
podcast will be there but the podcast is
far from over like we're not done with
the podcast podcast isn't finished not
at all not by any stretch of the
imagination also um me minions i'll have
some stuff in the works that we're
hoping we that we're hoping you guys
will enjoy we want to do some more
crossover stuff and we actually have a
really cool project that's being worked
on right now that we really want to
bring that we really wanted to bring to
you guys I think you guys are going to
enjoy but yeah you know so this video is
like eight and a half minutes long i'm
actually watching loss right now I'm one
season 2 episode not my let me tell you
something bout lost I never watched lost
when the show came on and I'm kicking
myself for it because this show is
amazing but everybody's telling me like
what you get to season 3 and then you
man and I'm like don't tell me that
don't ruin it for me so so yeah I'm lost
is pretty awesome so far like Michelle
Rodriguez is awesome in this show and
and here's my thing I haven't seen it
yet but i think the blonde chick the one
who says that she's like the
psychologists whatever it is I think
she's one of the others because she
never really brings him up and in that
instance when when what's his name when
mr. eko said that he had seen the others
and michelle rodriguez was like oh my
god everybody was freaking out except
for the blonde chick so I think the
blonde girl is as a member of the others
is one of the others who the others are
I have no earthly clue and I understand
why in the hell John Locke wanted to
press that button so bad I don't get
that like I would have sided with with
Jack I would have been like we're not
pressing that damn button like that's
stupid if the freaking island blows up
and it's going to blow up he'll it'll
save us living on the stand thing for 40
years or some [ __ ] or however long
Desmond was there like three years but
but yeah as you guys know I'm sorry
people I'm so I'm so excited about lost
like this show is amazing so anyway um
so yeah so we're going to bring this
video to an end and and yeah so I'll
catch you guys later peace